[Music]
mike's in buffalo hey mike welcome to
the ramsay show
hi dave thank you so much for taking my
call we greatly appreciate it sure man
what's up
um well i'll try to make this as as
quick as possible
big fan of yours
i i wish my life looked like i was a big
fan of source
basically the nuts and bolts of it right
now is that we've got a
uh a credit card judgment against us
the original debt was about fifteen
thousand they're coming after us for
about twenty thousand
um
after fees and interests
this is from discover
and
i'm trying to figure out what to do
they're trying to
well they're mistakenly saying that i'm
earning about four times what i actually
in order to try to take
10 of my income
um
we've got a friend who's an attorney
who's trying to help us sort through
that and
you know
stave that off but that's kind of a
band-aid we just recently got our tax
return which is about five thousand
dollars
and
um
you know we're trying to figure out
what's the best thing to do with that
given our current situation
okay
what's your household income
um well my um my wife brings in
um i forget exactly it's around 50 000
annually i'm
currently the stay-at-home dad
i
do work a couple of part-time jobs that
don't make a ton it's just basically you
know to
help with essentials and bills and how
do you know little things here and there
i've got three uh one is uh eight one's
five and one's three how'd you get this
far behind
oh boy
so
a while back with that particular card
um
we had runs and things up on it like our
honeymoon um
paid it off with a
uh a refinance on our house how long
have you been married was
uh close to ten years now okay we don't
need to go all the way back to the
honeymoon how did you get behind on your
discover card in recent history
okay well i mean it wasn't recent it was
several years ago now okay okay that's
fine all right here's what that's that's
what i was trying to do that's that's
the number i was trying to get so we're
good okay all right so here's the deal
um
number one the discover card problem is
not the problem it's the symptom
of the fact that your income is low in
this house
you're gonna have to make some different
decisions on careers
long term yeah i'm trying to figure out
how to do that yeah you're gonna have to
you don't ever it's time it's past time
to figure it out and this is a great
time to be looking for a job and a great
time to be getting a job both of you
maybe your wife gets a better job maybe
you get a job i don't know but we're
gonna have to do something here because
you've got three little kids and you're
living uh considerably below the average
household income in america in buffalo
which is not a cheap place to live
so uh i mean we did get lucky on our
house we live outside of buffalo don't
try to talk yourself out of this dude
you have an income problem no no yeah
okay i don't care how lucky you got it
you didn't get lucky enough to pay your
bills
so
and part of it is you've got three
mouths to feed you don't have a lot of
money coming in so we've got to get that
going we've got to get organized and get
on a budget we'll help you do all of
that as well
um
now as far as dealing with discover
here's the thing
are you sure you're dealing with
discover how you're probably not they
probably sold that debt haven't they
uh
i think so we were getting
calls from some ah okay the agency
that's what i thought
a debt that hasn't been paid on in this
long and they actually did sue you and
actually did get a judgment you're
saying
that's that's what it looks like yeah
unless they're sending us just flat out
and false
you know information
uh but it looks like it's stamped by our
local county sheriff's office okay
probably is and i doubt they i doubt
they'd go that far so debt buyers on old
credit card debt pay about a nickel on
the dollar
okay and so they probably paid a
thousand dollars for this twenty
thousand dollar debt
so i would offer them five thousand
dollars of settlement in full in cash
i don't have any more than that i'm
broke i have three kids we don't make
any money over here this is my tax
return and i will give it to you but i
will only give it to you there's other
people wanting this money i'm i'm behind
with everybody i'm getting ready to go
bankrupt a few people if i can't work
this out and i'm and you know and just
really whine and play a bad country song
in the radio right there in their ear
about how bad your life is and because
it is
and i got five thousand dollars and you
guys better take that while the getting
is good and you get it in writing from
them that this is settlement in full and
then you wire them the money no
electronic access to your checking
account do not give them any numbers of
any kind do not give them where she
works don't give them any information
make them find everything the hard way
but they'll settle this because they
probably got a grand in the debt they'll
probably take the five and walk
they're not going to in one conversation
you're going to bow up and be have a
little gravitas
all right but you can do that
two rules in writing
no electronic access to your checking
account
okay right now that solves the immediate
fire in the kitchen
but now we've got to figure out what why
we've been cooking with grease like this
and what's causing this right so yeah
and you got to get down under this and
fix the whole thing because you guys
have been wallowing around in financial
stress and it's affecting how you feel
about yourself it's affecting your
relationship and your marriage unless
you're not a human unless you're
psychotic it's affecting all of those
things it did when i went broke sure and
i about killed each other
yeah
mike do you have any other debt other
than the credit card
uh yeah i mean we both have student
loans
we have a mortgage we have
um
one other card that's in collections
for a much smaller amount
it's closer to like five or six thousand
um
but
they you know they haven't mentioned
anything for us on that
um and then we have a car loan that's
around
i think there's something like seven or
eight thousand left on it okay
well we're gonna get we're gonna put you
into financial peace university
and sign you guys up you and your wife
need to go through this together if you
can find a local church that's doing it
jump in there if not just do it online
with us
and get in some of the groups embrace
every detail of that
and assume like i did when i went broke
when i was 28 many years ago
assume that everything you're doing
right now is wrong and you should be
doing the opposite
because your life sucks man well i don't
want it i want you to win the last 10
years yeah i want you to win and you've
got to turn this around yeah so you hang
on we'll get you signed up and and you
call me back if you need some more help
george and i'll be here we're going to
be here for you we're going to walk with
you because it's scary as crud where you
live right now and i don't want you to
be there anymore i remember it it's not
fun
and you can get there you can win you
can turn this around check out a local
church and get plugged in get your
marriage going make sure you're getting
your bills paid get this settled and get
it out of your life you can turn this
around we can show you how